like peanut butter without the jelly or
a sailboat without the wind Snoop Dog
has quit smoking pot the rapper taking
to social media and saying quote after
much consideration and conversation with
my family I've decided to give up smoke
please respect my privacy at this time
Snoop has not elaborated more and why
he's giving up marijuana some speculate
that he could just be taking Edibles now
but maybe it's because weed is stronger
than ever a recent review of studies has
found higher concentrations of THC are
causing more people to become addicted
worldwide so Greg I think the likelihood
that snoo do wasn't addicted already is
basically zero I have a question for the
producers shouldn't we have done the
Oreo segment after this
segment you know you don't eat the
cookies before you get hot I love that
he's always been out in the open about
his smoking and then when he stops he
demands privacy it's like No it should
be the reverse I want to I want to know
what it's like for him to give it up he
should be an inspiration to all other
people that want to stop I think you
know as somebody that is Pro
decriminalization uh and I reject the
single variable thinking and but you see
this rise in mental illness on the
street and there are many variables
breakdown of society isolation Diet
alcohol but there's a correlation there
that a lot of this stuff is pretty
pretty powerful went from like one 1%
THC to in some cases 90% And as you know
I'm not an expert and I'm not a doctor
although I tell people I am just like Dr
Jill it
it's pretty powerful stuff and uh I I I
be you know you know you have to admit
that there might be something going on
even if you're pro- legalization and I
believe people can make their own
choices but when those choices infringe
on the freedoms of other people you got
to take a look yep judge what do you
think um leaving the prosecutor out uh
on this I think it's very interesting
that um he says please respect my
privacy and he has this incredible post
where he's like like this and it's
almost like he's praying please respect
my privacy there it is up there uh but
my producer uh Roman had a great idea he
said to me not only is he probably doing
edibles but I bet he's going to come out
with a line of Edibles which is why he's
not you know he's saying I need my
privacy don't ask me how I feel but
there's also so kudos to Roman but you
know now that he's not smoking anymore
Greg you know he was paying a guy
$60,000 a year to roll his Blunts and
I'm sure if he wants to write a
recommendation and have this guy come to
you uh that recommendation would be
valuable to you no it's another job lost
under the Joe Biden
Administration I can't wait till Trump
brings back all the blunt
rollers they'll be they'll be rolled in
America Jessica no all his stuff is made
in China don't do that okay go ahead
that was hilarious um so Snoop dogs does
anyone know his real name by the way
brus clay or clay yes Calvin brus Jr I
love this Snoop Dog this is fantastic he
earlier in the year said he wanted to
cut back on marijuana due to health
concerns and he said quote he wants to
see his grandkids grow old so what a
great example to kids everywhere we know
THC is off the roof psychosis all these
things that come with the new marijuana
he could really be a leader on this and
good for him to put the grandkids first
so he smokes a half pound of pot a day
which is equal to 75 to 150 joints he
estimates he's smoked uh over a million
joints and blunts in his lifetime that's
a lot I get the idea that of
decriminalization I get that but it's
amazing how the the most uh the fastest
most successful political movement in
the country today is decriminalizing pot
and everybody is smoking pot now you
can't walk anywhere without smoking pot
and you have to ask yourself why is that
well of course the reason is because
states have realized that they can get
tax dollars from it which is what the
reason there's so much money behind it
but is it really helping us I don't I
mean you walk around up and down the
streets and like you we have an epidemic
of of uselessness in this country you
have an epidemic of obesity in this
country you have all these epidemics of
people not working does this help any of
it and I don't think it does I think it
makes it worse you know what you're
seeing though fewer drunks isn't that
remember when we were growing up it was
drunk guys wandering around the street
the brown the brown bag and now that's
been replaced by this well now that
instead of driving drunk they're driving
while their ability to drive is impaired
by drugs same but alcohol kills people
oh and drugs don't no I'm just saying
marijuana I it's really hard to find a
an overdose from it depends on what it's
laced gonna kill me well I'm not talking
about laced I'm talking about marijana I
know I know but it can be and you know
that's well everything could be laced
judge that's right your tea could be
laced I would check in the break cuz I
saw Jessica drop something in there
Jessica did nothing um people who are
benefiting from it are folks who are
being put away for low-level drug
offenses with legalization hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else